>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Karyn Temple Claggett:
Thank you and welcome
to the Coolidge Auditorium
as we celebrate World IP Day,
Innovation Improving Lives.
My name is Karyn Temple Claggett
and I'm currently Acting Register
of the US Copyright Office.
We are pleased to once
again this year partner
with the Copyright
Alliance on this event
and we are particularly
thrilled to have a special guest,
Representative Doug Collins,
who I will formally
introduce in just a moment.
But first, I want to take a moment
to reflect on this year's theme
from a copyright perspective.
We know that copyrighted
works such as books, films,
and music entertain the world but
do they actually improve lives,
as the theme of this year's
World IP Day celebrates?
Well, I expect for most
of us in the audience
that question is a rhetorical one.
Whether it is the way that
copyrighted works inspire us
like the iconic photograph of the
first female Boston Marathon runner
by Harry Trask, or the
way they impact change
in the political environment
like the groundbreaking novel,
The Jungle, by Upton Sinclair, or
the way they humanize the struggle
for equality such as
the searing photograph
of Emmett Till's open
casket in Jet Magazine,
copyrighted works improve our
lives in immeasurable ways.
They make us laugh,
they make us think,
and in many instances,
they make us act.
In fact, copyrighted works can
actually impact our very health
and well-being.
According to one study,
listening to music prior
to surgery actually lowered
patient's anxiety better
than medication.
Another study pointed out something
I think we all know inherently
and probably have heard from
our parents since kindergarten,
that reading a novel enhances
connectivity in the brain
and improves brain function.
Simply put, it makes us smarter.
As a CNN article recently
acknowledged,
books can literally
change your life.
Even videogames, which
are often seen by parents
as really just mere
child's play can,
according to the American
Psychological Association,
strengthen cognitive skills such
as reason, memory, and perception
and copyrighted works such as
software directly improve lives
by allowing people with
disabilities to access the world
in ways never imaginable before.
Software allows those
with amputated, paralyzed,
or impaired limbs to operate
computers and navigate the internet.
It can magnify and read
text on computer screens
for those with sight impairments.
In short, innovative
software has opened the door
to an entirely new world of
knowledge for many who thought
that certain life experiences
were forever lost.
So, while this year's
theme for World IP Day,
Innovation Improving Lives may
not have immediately brought
to mind the role of copyright and
copyrighted works in our society,
it is fact very fitting description
of how important copyright
and copyrighted works are to our
culture and our everyday lives
because of course, without copyright
law which gives artists, authors
and other creators the ability
to actually make a living
in the pursuit of their creativity,
many of our most iconic songs,
films, and books simply
would not exist.
For example, it was a full-time
photojournalist who took that photo
of Kathrine Switzer running
the Boston Marathon in 1967,
that impacted and inspired female
runners for many years to come.
It was a full-time writer who
wrote the iconic book, The Jungle,
which encouraged concrete
legislative changes
for the US workforce and
it took hundreds of workers
in the film industry, all
supported by copyright law
to complete the groundbreaking
films Norma Rae, Philadelphia,
The Thin Blue Line, and
Moonlight and many, many others,
which have inspired
and touched thousands.
Copyright, as the Supreme
Court has stated,
is the engine of free expression and
sometimes it is even more than that.
Many creators have used their
copyrights to directly improve lives
through a wide variety
of charitable endeavors.
For example, Anne Frank's
father registered her copyright
but the proceeds of the sale of The
Diary of Anne Frank have been used
to fund The Anne Frank
Foundation's charitable initiatives
and many musicians have often
banded together to create
and perform benefit songs.
The famous song, We Are
The World for example,
raised more than 75 million
dollars for famine relief.
Finally, as the examples you'll see
during the discussion later today
demonstrate, artists
often use technology
and other innovative
tools themselves
to improve their own
creativity and artistry.
So again, while it may not have
been quite obvious at first glance,
this year's theme for World IP
Day is perfectly, perfectly suited
to celebrate copyright
as we know it today.
[ Applause ]
>> Karyn Temple Claggett : And with
that as a backdrop, we are honored
to have with us someone who has
championed and supported copyright
and the Copyright Office directly
throughout his time in Congress,
Representative Doug Collins.
Representative Collins first
came to Washington in 2013.
In just a few years, he has been
one of the most passionate advocates
for creators in the
House of Representatives.
He currently serves as Vice Chair
of the judiciary's committee
subcommittee on courts,
intellectual property, and
the internet and in 2014,
he succeeded the late Chairman
Howard Coble as the Co-Chair
of the Creative Rights Caucus.
Along with democratic Co-Chair
Representative Judy Chu,
Representative Collins works on a
bipartisan basis through the caucus
to uphold the constitutionally
mandated protections of the rights
of the creative community.
Representative Collins proudly
touts the openness of his home state
of Georgia, which has provided a
friendly environment for artists
to engage in creative
processes there.
As he has said before, copyright
is the foundation of innovation
and innovation is the force
that drives our economy.
We are very, very pleased
and fortunate
to have Representative Collins
here today to lend his voice
to this worldwide celebration
of innovation, copyright
and how it changes
and improves lives.
Please join me in welcoming
Representative Doug Collins.
[ Applause ]
>> Doug Collins: Thank you.
It is a pleasure to be here.
For those who were here last night,
there was a show we did again just
to continue that whole theme
with the [inaudible] Foundation
in songwriting and I see my friends
in the audience and see others
that we've worked with
over the past few years.
I want to thank you for
the invitation to be here.
It is a special day, happy
World Intellectual Property Day,
happy IP Day.
We'll get a cake out, we'll dance,
we'll sing, we'll do whatever,
it's creative, we'll do it!
One of the things I want
to think today though is,
when you look at what was
just described so eloquently
about the theme for this year's
event is innovation improving lives
and you can talk about it from
a lot of different perspectives.
You just saw on the screen,
you've heard about it
as how things have changed
lives, that creative spark,
that creative use that changes
lives but I am going to come at it
from just a little bit different
perspective on this World IP Day
because I am going to come at it
from a perspective of how this
in many ways, even when I
did not know it, changed me.
How intellectual property, at
the time when I was growing up,
had no idea of what
that even stood for,
would not even have comprehended
what intellectual property would
mean to me because if
somebody were to tell me,
I wouldn't have recognized
it in its form.
In fact, one of the things that
I'll challenge us here today
on World IP Day is to begin to think
differently on how we discuss IP,
intellectual property, copyright,
patent, we go down the list.
If it was important enough
to involve the Constitution
of the United States, it should
be important enough for us today
to be able to explain it in
very simple terms to everyone
in our country on why
this is important
and why copyright protection
is valuable to the economy
of not only our financial sector
but it is valuable to the economy
of the soul, because I was a kid
who grew up in northeast Georgia,
a beautiful part of the world.
I'd encourage anyone to come and
especially if you're making a movie,
we have a lot of places for
you to come and if you listen
to any radio stations,
especially country
in the last few years you understand
that Georgia is the great place
to do that but I grew up there
as a State Trooper's kid.
My dad was a dedicated public
servant who worked for 31 years
for the Georgia State Patrol and
in one of those regards it's almost
like a lot of what I do now, we
did not have a lot of vacation time
and when we did, we only could get
away for a little bit because dad,
as a state law enforcement officer,
would have to work those times.
So for me, when I thought of
intellectual property at a time
which I did not, I just
thought of the things that I,
besides being in the woods, and
being in the fishing, and lake
and doing things, I would
come back to my room
and I would have my music,
and I would have my books.
It was once said that no person
could ever be bound to anywhere
as long as there was a book in their
hand and for me, that was true.
For listening to a song that could
take me from the room in my house,
or my back porch, or
standing in the front yard,
imitating that I was
performing for millions of people
at a worldwide stage, it was
something inside of me although
for me who could not sing very well,
the words still took me
away to a different place.
In books, I found the strength to
carry on sometimes when I was down.
I found the hope to say
there's something better
and that there's ways that
we can improve our lives.
I found in books and music, I
found the ability to cross oceans
and to cross plains and to find
out what happens from the beginning
of time to my time and how
do I apply it to myself?
So the question is
not very hard for me,
how did innovation improve
lives, it improved mine.
It took me from a place
in Gainesville,
Georgia to now being humbly standing
before you as the Congressman
from the ninth district of Georgia.
When that occurs, you begin to
think of how do we communicate.
I mentioned just a moment ago,
I want us to begin to think
about how we communicate the World
Intellectual Property Day is not
some off the wall kind of thing
that only lawyers or geeky folks,
or folks who are creators get into.
This is something for everybody.
It is something we should trumpet
and triumph throughout the world
because it is the very thing that
will inspire the next generation
of those who will sit in this room
or those maybe standing behind
this podium but we've got to get
into the mode of talking about when
we discuss intellectual property,
and for those who have heard me
speak before this is truly a passion
of mine.
I do not want us to talk in sections
and code numbers and bill numbers,
I want to talk about
the dreams, and hopes,
and aspirations that
copyright protects.
It gives the incentive there's
been a move in our country and even
across the ocean to say that well,
we don't need as much
copyright protection
and intellectual property
protection.
We need to make it just
sort of free and available.
I will tell you right now
that if we go down a path
of weakening our copyright,
our structure of intellectual
property protections then we're
weakening the very
system of innovation
that has driven our
country for over 200 years.
[ Applause ]
>> Doug Collins: Do
not let anyone tell you
that the protections
provided in the copyright,
and the intellectual
property protections provided
in our law are not a
disincentive to creation,
they're the reason for creation.
Why would I want to go out and not
be able to do what my heart's call,
what my passion in life to do
if there were not protected
rights to do so?
I have fed my family for all of
my adult life, I didn't realize it
until just a few years
ago, with simply what comes
out for the most part of my mind and
my heart and my mouth and my hands.
I can farm, I can do a little bit
of construction, I can get by,
I can work but when it came to
the true passion in my life,
I believe God invested in me
the ability to communicate
and to share vision and
the only way I did that was
through intellectual property.
Didn't know it at the time,
that's why I came to this job
with such a different perspective
so when you begin to talk about this
and why it's important and you
talk to other members of Congress,
and you talk to just your friends
at the grocery store, the bakery,
or the ballgame, you
talk about it in terms
of innovation changing lives.
You talk about that song that
right now if I said think of a song
that takes you from this place to
wherever, good or bad sometimes,
songs can take you that
way, you could name one.
Think of the book that you read
that inspired you to do something
in your life that maybe changed
your perspective on something
that you had never thought about
and think of where it came from,
the heart and passion and
mind of somebody who were able
to take advantage of the copyright
and intellectual property
protections we have
to take us far beyond
where we are now.
We have to think differently.
If we do not think differently
then we're headed down a path
in letting others define
what this role means.
We're headed down a path
in which others will define
that limited copyright is
better and that freedom is okay
and that everybody just graze.
I'm telling you this, if we head
down that path then we are headed
towards a second rate economy
because there's nothing
in our economic system
that is not dependent
upon the protections
of intellectual property.
When we understand that, then I
have a challenge for you today.
My challenge for us today is to not
simply accept the world right here
as it is in intellectual property.
My challenge for us today is I
have shared in committee meetings
and hearings about this all over
this country is, it is now time
as you talk about songs and music,
we talk about how they have changed.
For those of us in the room that
still remember buying a 45 record
and thinking that was the coolest
thing because you saved up 99 cents
to go get it, to having a cassette
tape (yes, they still exist),
eight tracks, CDs, streaming,
just in my short lifetime.
So my challenge to you today is,
how do we protect intellectual
copyright,
how do we protect our copyright
statues and how do we prepare them
for the next 30 to 40 years,
not just the next one?
When we get limited in our vision
then we lose the whole scope
of intellectual property
and copyright protection.
I challenge you today to begin
to think outside of the box.
Disruptive technologies
and disruptive thoughts
will always be here,
they're incorporated
inherently into the very system
because inherently those disrupting
thoughts and disrupting mediums
that we tend to deal with today,
especially in music all have
to also come back into
the protection
of this very same thing
that they're disrupting.
Some of us don't want to think about
that but the idea for streaming,
the idea for a new way of music
delivery also enjoys the protection
of intellectual property.
Let's not have us against them,
let's say where do we want to be
in the years to come so
that in 30 or 40 years,
those sitting in this wonderful
auditorium will say you know,
those folks back in 2017,
they celebrated World IP Day
by saying how it improves lives
and 40 years in the future,
somebody will be able to
stand here and proudly say,
they picked up the mantle, they
began to explain it in terms
that matters to individuals
on the street, and they began
to make a difference so that they
can stand here on that podium
on that day and say
intellectual property is something
worth protecting.
Intellectual property is what drives
our economy, it is what makes us
who we are and I for one am not
going to back up or back down
or look away, because I am that
child from northeast Georgia
who used the dreams of others
to inspire me to have dreams
that I now deposit in my wife and
my three children, so that they can
in turn give that gift to others.
Today, dream big.
Don't step back, don't give up, and
World IP Day will remind everyone
of the importance of the hopes,
dreams, and ambitious of us all.
God bless you, have a great day.
[ Applause ]
>> Karyn Temple Claggett:
Thank you so much,
that was really truly
inspiring, inspiring words.
Now we'll have Keith Kupferschmid,
who will give special remarks
before we turn it over to the panel.
Thank you.
>> Keith Kupferschmid: I guess
I must have drawn the short
straw here.
How do I follow that, not to mention
the Acting Register's fantastic
remarks and then I'm in between a
wonderful panel you have here too.
Can I just simply, would it
be copyright infringement
to say what he said and
what she said [laughter]?
I don't know but I do want
to thank a bunch of people.
I want to thank first
off the Copyright Office
and the Acting Register.
We've been partnering with
them for I guess six years now
and it's just fabulous
to be able to put this
on every World IP Day together,
obviously Representative Collins
who just gave such a
fabulous opening remarks.
I also want to thank Pat Collins
from [inaudible] and Barbara Zadina,
who is the CEO of Higher Ground, for
helping us put this panel together
and of course the moderator and the
panelists which you'll see shortly.
So, I am Keith Kupferschmid, the
CEO of the Copyright Alliance.
For those of you who are unfamiliar
with the Copyright Alliance
and hopefully that's a
dwindling few at this point,
but for those dwindling
few out there,
we represent the copyright
interests of close
to two million individual creators,
creators like photographers
and performers, software coders and
songwriters, artists and authors,
and many, many others who make a
living through their creativity.
We also represent the
copyright interests
of over 13,000 different
organizations across a spectrum
of different copyright disciplines
ranging from motion picture studios
and record labels to book, magazine,
newspaper publishers, software
and video game companies, even
sports leagues so anyone pretty much
who has a copyright interest
whether it's an organization
or individual is a
member of the alliance.
What our mission is, is to dedicate
ourselves to advocating for policies
that promote and preserve the
value of copyright as well
as to protecting the rights
of creators and innovators.
The individual creators and the
organizations that we represent rely
on copyright to protect
their creativity,
to protect their efforts, and
to protect their investments
in the creation and distribution
of new copyrighted works
for the public to enjoy.
Now, the title of this year's
program the World IP celebration
as you've heard is
Innovation Improving Lives
and our event today will focus
on the impact of creative works
and performances on the lives
of both creators and the public.
In the spirit of that theme,
I'd just like to say a few words
about the importance of copyright
as a means for spurring innovation
and spurring creation and how
that benefits the public
and improves lives.
Copyright is a unique form
of property that is grounded
in an artist's own creativity,
hard work, and talent.
In many ways, it epitomizes the
American dream and I think you heard
that of course from
Representative Collins
and Acting Register Temple Claggett.
Copyright is about empowerment.
It gives the creator the power
to determine when, where,
and how their creative genius can
be used by others and importantly,
to get compensated for that use.
A copyright belongs to the creator
from the time that work is created
and recorded in some tangible
form regardless of whether
that work is registered or any
formal action has been taken.
Copyright is also about freedom.
It is core to protecting
our first amendment rights
of freedom of expression.
It also gives authors the freedom to
create and to thrive and the freedom
to create free from
outside influence.
Importantly, copyright also
supports individuals freedom
to pursue a career and make
a living creating new works
for the public to enjoy.
A focus on and a respect for
creators rights reflects the value
of our country, that our
country was built on and I think,
as you all realize, has its
roots in our Constitution.
As one of the few constitutionally
enumerated powers
of the federal government,
this grant of authority
reflects the founders belief
that insuring appropriate rights
to creators drives innovation
and benefits society and
this remains true today just
as it was true over 200 years ago.
A robust, well-functioning, and up
to date copyright act is important
to all stakeholder,
especially the general public
which is the ultimate beneficiary
of a well-functioning system.
The public benefits from the
intellectual and cultural diversity
that results from the incentives to
create that are rooted in copyright.
Now unfortunately, there are
some groups, let's call them sort
of copyright non-believers,
I'm not sure if there's any
in the audience here, that
like to pit creators rights
against the public
interest and in doing so,
they ignore the copyright laws
internal balancing mechanisms
which is ultimately detrimental
to the goals of copyright.
Setting creators rights on one
scale and the public interest
on the other is both one
dimensional and detrimental
to the overall goals of copyright.
The underlying assumption is that
creator's interests are distinct
from the public interest and
that one can only be furthered
at the expense of the other.
I'm here to tell you
that is not the case.
I think you've heard from others
that that is not the case.
It seems more accurate to
describe the creator's interest
and the public interest
as inter-related
and mutually reinforcing.
After all, in a very
basic sense the performer
and the audience need each other.
Likewise, the author and reader.
The idea behind copyright
is that a marketable right
and tangible expression that a
creator produces is the best way
to advance both of those interests.
By keeping in mind the intertwined
nature of the private right
and the public gain, we can
better reach a more balanced
and healthy approach to
copyright protection so with that,
let me introduce, not
take any more time away
from our panel or our moderation.
Let me introduce our
moderator Eric Schwartz.
Eric is, probably there's no one
better to moderate this session.
He is not only a fantastic attorney
but also has experience in some
of the things we'll talk about
today with regard to Soundbreaking.
Eric has over 25 years of
experience as a copyright attorney,
providing counseling on US
and foreign copyright laws.
He has also served as a
transactional attorney experienced
in production, distribution and
financing of musical recordings
and well as featured
in documentary films.
He also has served as
Chief Production Counsel
for the PBS series Soundbreaking,
the eight hour documentary
about the history of recorded
music, which aired nationwide
in November 2016 and will
be discussed quite a bit
in the panel that's to follow.
As a result of all the work
Eric did on Soundbreaking,
he received a producer's credit
for his assistance with the product
so as you hear, Eric kind
of knows just a little bit
about what we're going
to talk about today.
And in addition to that,
for over the last 20 years,
he has served on the
Library of Congress' Film
and Recorded Sound
Preservation Boards.
He has helped found the National
Film Preservation Foundation
and prior to private practice, Eric
also served as a Senior Attorney
and Acting General Counsel at
the US Copyright Office so Eric,
if you'd like to come on up?
[ Applause ]
>> Eric Schwartz: Thank you
Keith and thank you also to Jody
and Eileen at the Copyright Alliance
and thank you Karyn and Katie
at the US Copyright Office and
all at the Copyright Office
for hosting us and especially thank
you to Congressman Doug Collins,
both for all your support
for creators and for advocacy
for strong copyright protection
and as demonstrated this morning,
you can hear the passion
that he has for the topic.
As you've heard, World IP Day
is a celebration of the role
of intellectual property,
copyrights,
and patents in encouraging
innovation and creativity.
Our event here this morning is meant
to focus on the role of songwriters,
performers, recording engineers, and
produces in the recording process.
We'll also illustrate the
importance of recording technology
as a creative tool, we'll show you
a clip in a few minutes, and lastly
and more broadly, we'll talk about
how copyright law rewards creators
and in doing so, encourages
them to create
and disseminate their works
to the general public.
Now, before I introduce the
two guests seated next to me,
we have a special message
from Linda Perry.
Linda, as you may know, was listed
on the program but unfortunately had
to drop off at the last minute
due to a scheduling conflict.
She is after all, a
working producer.
In fact, Linda is a Grammy winning
producer of Christina Aguilera.
We'll show a segment of her
work later in the program.
Also, Alicia Keys, Gwen
Stefani, and James Blunt.
She's also a singer/songwriter,
most notably with 4 Non Blondes
where she composed the song
and she was also their lead vocalist
including their hit song What's Up.
Linda couldn't be here so she sent
a clip in lieu of her attendance
so John if will, let's
show the clip of Linda.
Well thank you Linda,
and she was being harsh
on herself for not being here.
We appreciated that she was going to
redeye in and fly out this evening,
so let me welcome our
two guests who are here.
I'll start first to my left
with Steve Bogard and then
to his left Jason King,
I'll introduce in a minute.
Steve is based in Nashville so
he's been a successful songwriter
of hit songs for many performers
including Lee Greenwood, Etta James,
George Strait and Rascal Flatts.
Steve was also fortunate to
work in the recording studio
with legendary producer and
engineer Tom Dowd during the Derek
and the Dominos sessions,
when they recorded Layla.
They, who recorded those
sessions if you don't know,
was one of those stellar bands,
Eric Clapton, Duane Allman,
I think they had a guitarist
named George Harrison sitting in.
Steve's also an advocate
on behalf of songwriters,
very passionate advocate
working with the National
Songwriter's
Association International.
To demonstrate some
of Steve's works,
we have a short clip we're
going to play for you now.
It's a song entitled Seeing
Red, performed by David Lynch.
The song was a Billboard country
airplay number one just a couple
of weeks ago and it's Steve's latest
number one song, he's had many.
So John, if you'll play this
clip we'll get a sample.
[ Applause ]
>> Steve Bogard: Thank you.
>> Eric Schwartz: Thank you and as
much as we'd love to hear all of it
and all of Jason's song too
we'll just stop it there.
Tell us a bit about the song.
>> Steve Bogard: Well, I think
it exemplifies the influences
of hip-hop and pop and rock
music in the country genre.
We wrote it kind of like
a band would write a song,
instead of the traditional Nashville
start with a title and a hook
and a well-crafted lyric we
kind of started with a lick
and somebody said I'm seeing red
and I said well, I know how to write
that and so it just kind
of moved on from there.
It kind of focuses on
passion and that sort of thing
and it was a number one record.
I'm proud of it.
[ Applause ]
>> Eric Schwartz: Well
congratulations.
So, to Steve's left is Jason
King, who's based in New York.
We've really covered our music bases
so we thought we had with Linda
from LA, New York, and Nashville.
Jason teaches about the
business of recorded music
and is frequently used as an expert
in documentary films about music
and the history of recorded sound
as well as in copyright cases
but as you'll hear in a minute, he's
also a songwriter and performer.
He's a host of both
CNN and NPR podcasts
on music among his
many other talents.
I love the first line of your
bio which says that Jason is,
and this is the quote, "A musician,
DJ, performer, producers, arranger,
songwriter, scholar,
curator, and journalist."
That's something else.
He's Associate Professor
and founding faculty member
of the Clive Davis
Institute of Recorded Music
at New York University in
the Tisch School of the Arts.
Some of his classroom guests
have included Pharrell Williams,
two of my favorites the
songwriting duo of Gamble and Huff,
a fan of Harold Melvin and the Blue
Notes among others, Phil Ramone
and Alicia Keys so
Jason welcome as well.
We have a clip from one of
Jason's songs called Crackdown,
performed by his band
Company Freak and John,
if you will let's hear
a bit of that.
>> Eric Schwartz: Thank
you for that.
[ Applause ]
>> Eric Schwartz: Tell us
something about the writing
of that and performance of that.
>> Jason King: Thanks, I wanted to
play some funky music for you early
in the morning here so
that's my band company Freak.
The idea of the band is to return
to the sound of classic soul,
funk and disco of the 1970s,
that moment when there was
sophisticated song craft,
and arranging, and production in New
York in particular, groups like Chic
and Change that congregated
around clubs like Studio 54
and the Paradise Garage and so
the band is multi-generational.
There's 22 people in the
band, everyone from people
who are 19 years old all the way up
to 75, and there are classic legends
in the band, musicians and singers
from those groups like Chic as well
as legends in the making.
The reason I wanted
to play that track is
because I think it's a good
demonstration of the way
that creativity in music can happen
in a way that I would call composite
so in other words in distinction
from the idea of just going
into a recording studio with a
band and just putting mics up
and recording everything,
which is how it used
to happen way back in the day.
This is really recorded out
of sequence and out of step,
which is how a lot of recording,
I'm sure Steve can agree a lot
of recording happens these days
so that song started
off as a different song.
I has this first line which
is, "Every crooked politician
on an anti-human mission, good for
them but not for me" not referring
to any politicians in
this room [laughter]
but there are some crooked
politicians in the world,
but not here and so,
I had that line.
I had written a song around
that line but I didn't really
like the song but I
wanted to keep that line.
I was teaching in the Middle
East, I partly teach in New York,
partly teach in the Middle East
and I kept hearing this word
on the news crackdown,
crackdown, and so I then came
up with this line,
"If you're thinking
about doing a crackdown you'd
better crack down on yourself"
so it was a kind of commentary
of political hypocrisy
and those kinds of things.
And then, recorded part of the
instrumental in Istanbul in Turkey
with some musicians there, so
then I had a little bit of a track
and brought it back to
New York and finished it
with my keyboard player Hubert Eaves
from the group D Train and a number
of other really talented
session musicians
and then I still didn't
even have a lyric
so then I put the lyric together and
then I finally recorded the vocal
on it so that's me singing but I
wanted to do kind of like a Sly
and the Family Stone kind of early
70s funk thing so I ended up kind
of pitching my voice
so it sounds like it's
in a different kind of place.
And then what I did
finally when I had the song,
I actually switched all the parts
so the verse that I had recorded end
up becoming the chorus, the chorus
was the verse because you can do
that with technology and so it
actually became a totally different
song than the one I originally
intended but it's a song
that I really admire because of
the way that it came together.
>> Eric Schwartz: Thank you, which,
the part about the technology
is a perfect segue way
because we're going to talk now
for a few minutes about the role
of technology in creativity and
we're going to demonstrate it
as we are for the remainder
of the program with some clips
from the documentary series which
Keith referred to, Soundbreaking,
Stories From the Cutting
Edge of Recorded Music.
Soundbreaking is, as
Keith mentioned,
an eight-hour PBS documentary.
It aired nationwide last
November over eight nights.
Interestingly, for those of
you here in DC, it was produced
by Higher Ground right here at
Dupont Circle, Barbara Zadina one
of the producers is here
with us today and thank you
for supplying the clips to us.
It was produced in association
with legendary Beatles Producer Sir
George Martin and by the filmmakers
in New York, Show of Force.
The series was Sir George's
legacy project to tell stories
of his experiences 60 years
in the music industry.
He's the one who signed the Beatles
when every other record
label had turned them down.
He and his son Giles worked on
the series for over a decade,
which in itself tells you something
about the creative process,
that it took 10 years to
make this documentary.
Happily, he lived to
see the final cut of it.
George passed away a year ago March.
The series includes 200 artists,
so pretty much everyone knowing
that this was Sir George's series
said put me in so you have Paul,
and Ringo, and Eric Clapton and
Elton John, Linda Perry, Jason King,
somehow Steve, I don't
know why we missed you.
It has 175 archival clips
and hundreds of music cues
and I should mention since
this is a copyright audience,
all licensed material.
No fair usage in this series.
The first clip we're going
to watch is six minutes long.
It's from episode 102 and it's
called Painting With Sound
and it's a fantastic
illustration to Jason's points,
about the use of technology only
this was the use of technology
in the mid-1960s, in this
case during the recording
of the Beatles song, Tomorrow
Never Knows and how innovation
and technology were
used in the process,
even a fairly rudimentary
one of the 1960s so John,
if you'll roll the first clip, we'll
watch a segment from Soundbreaking.
[ Applause ]
>> Eric Schwartz: It was
incredible stuff for the time
and in an analog era, so let me ask
each of you talking a little bit
about the use of technology, Jason
will start first I mean you referred
to it, it is a tool but it
can be an overwhelming tool.
How do you sort of reign it in
with the ability to do everything
that you want, when you watch
that clip and you realize this was
on four tracks and they had
to sort of live perform it?
How do you stop yourself from
using too much technology?
>> Jason King: Legendary producer
Brian Eno always said even
if you have a lot of options
you should limit the options
and you should just use few options
so that you can actually burrow sort
of more deeply into what those
are so he would cite the example
of Jimi Hendrix, who would
always use the same Stratocaster
and the same guitar.
He always had a particular
instrument and amp
that he would always use as
opposed to just trying to run
through a variety of
different technologies.
Today, we have a lot more options
and to some degree
options can be a problem
because if you have too many
options then what you might do is
for instance, go to a synthesizer
looking for the exact right sound
that you wanted and spend five hours
just looking for that sound rather
than just taking one sound
and working with that alone.
I mean, this clip is really
interesting because I think
to some degree, it lands us in
the 60s where you see the rise
of the recording studio as
kind of a creative laboratory
and it's the time in which
the studio starts to take
on this mythology as a place
where these studio wizards
like George Martin, who produced
the Beatles, or Phil Spector go in
and create these masterpieces
whether it's Sergeant Pepper's
Lonely Hearts Club Band
or the Revolver album
or Jimi Hendrix Electric Lady.
>> Eric Schwartz: And it
also compares, you know,
Brian Wilson in the Beach Boys
trying to outdo the Beatles
and their back and forth thing
and they're using the studio
as that laboratory as
you say, to do that.
>> Jason King: Yeah, to create new
sounds that we haven't heard before
from Pet Sounds the Beach Boys,
to Sergeant Pepper's, Revolver,
all of these albums that occurred
in the 60s really opened up the way
that we think about music and its
relationship to technology but prior
to this era, we were
really in a stage
of what you'd call a
documentarian producing so the idea
that you would only really
record bands or performers
who were worth recording.
Ella Fitzgerald was a great
singer and all you had
to do was just take what she had
done in the club and just bring it
into the recording studio
and just try and capture it
in the best way possible with
as much fidelity to the sound
of what you would hear live in the
recording studio and of course,
the creative decisions that were
being made in this documentarian era
of producing but for the most
part you were just trying
to capture a great live performance
but in the 60s with The Beatles,
what you see is the rise of
trying to create sonic fantasies
as Tony Visconte, the
producer, was saying here.
You're trying to create
these surreal worlds
that could never actually exist in
real life so the idea of Revolver,
the idea of Sergeant Peppers
or Jimi Hendrix albums or Sly
and the Family Stone or
anybody who was doing this kind
of amazing production was to take
you not back to the live performance
in your head but to take you to
a world that could only exist
in the context of recording.
>> Eric Schwartz: Right although the
capturing live is something that's
still very much a skill even today
and is still very much a part
of recording and I suppose the
pendulum swing where bands Nashville
in particular, want to
capture just as accurately
as possible the fidelity of live.
>> Steve Bogard: In many cases,
I think it's interesting,
I almost see it as a circle because
if you think about Sam Phillips
and tape delay and the first
people who discovered how
to do echo chamber with a speaker
and a mic and you move that on
to maybe visions that a producer has
on up to The Beatles and a situation
where it couldn't be
reproduced live.
I was just at a Keith Urban Grammy
hype party to get you to vote
for him for Album of the Year,
which he deserved and he has a guy
in his band he plays
something called the phantom
and the phantom is just
a big old box that wheels
out and it's all samples.
It's an embarrassment of riches of
samples so that every single song
on his record, this guy that plays
the phantom can put the samples
on for the background
vocals, for the guitar riffs,
for the string section, for
whatever is there so it's almost
as if we've gone to the
recording studio as an instrument.
We bring the recording
studio to the live stage.
There are lots of concerts
that you can go
to where you know they're
not playing.
>> Eric Schwartz: And that was the
issue of course for The Beatles
when they came off of the road and
said we're never going to be able
to play this live,
they just couldn't do
that where the studio was the venue
for making music and now it's sort
of both, to the criticism
of some of their live shows.
>> Steve Bogard: And Nashville has
changed just in the last five years
or so with the ubiquitous
availability of samples
and we call them track guys.
I was just at a writer's retreat
with Warner Brothers and my company
and the hostess said okay,
I've got you guys all set up,
I've got four rooms where
everybody's got the rigs
in the rooms and in each room
we're going to have an artist,
we're going to have a track guy, and
we're going to have a writer writer
and luckily I got to be a
writer writer but we had a lot
of fun gigging her about the
fact that we're all writers,
it's just that some of us are the
traditional songwriter, lyric,
melody people and some of us are
more attuned to the track guy thing.
It's really hurt the live musician
income stream, the advent of people
who are programmers who are
excellent at choosing the millions
of samples there are to choose
from and creating demos,
creating demonstrations of songs.
>> Eric Schwartz: Yeah that's
tough so I'm cognizant of time
and we're going to now show another
clip but keep the discussion going.
This is from episode 108 of the
series called, I am my Music,
which focuses on the role
of innovation and technology
in the dissemination of music,
which as this is the story
often told the good and the bad
because simultaneously, this
technology allowed the distribution
and access to unauthorized
music so John,
if you'll roll the
second clip please.
What's interesting is that the
second segment sort of ends the era
and we're ending for time
and then what happened
after when the music industry was
allowed to roll out its own services
of course, there are now 70 music
streaming services in the US
with 30 million songs so more
music legally is now available
than at any time in the
history of recorded sound
so the system sort of works.
There were a couple of
things in that segment,
one of course Bob Ludwig's
remarks about Brother in Arms.
I bought my CD player when I bought
that album and my stereo system
so I guess I fit right
in that demographic
but the emotional connection when
Knopfler talks about the songs
and how you never expect
the emotional connection
that your songs would have but
Jason, you had the line in there
about private listening
and I was wondering how
if at all has the change to private
listening changed the creative
process, the way in which
songs are written and made
and then I'll ask you
the same question.
>> Jason King: It's a big question.
You know, I think one of the
things that it's easy to forget is
that if you were listening to an
orchestra play classical music
in the 19th century you
were in a particular space
that was bounded like, you were
in a concert hall listening
to this music, sitting in a
seat and having this experience.
And one of the results of
the technological changes
of the 20th century is that music
suddenly becomes unbounded in space
through recording so a
recording allows you to be able
to hear music outside of the space
in which it's actually performed
and so once you can do that, then
it changes the way that we think
about music altogether and then
with the advent of other kinds
of technology like magnetic tape
and multi-tracking technology
that allows you to
record multiple tracks,
suddenly recording becomes a
very different thing altogether
that you can take parts out and
put parts back in, you can add,
you can subtract, you
can manipulate,
you can actually change the
nature of sound in a way
that was totally different
to what you would have
seen in previous eras.
And the other, I think big change
in the 20th century is the fact
that music becomes portable so as
opposed to having to listen to it
in a particular bounded
space in time,
suddenly you can take
your music with you.
You can listen to your Kanye West
album anywhere that you want to
and we just take it for granted
but that didn't always exist
and so once music becomes
unbounded in space and time
and once you can add and subtract
and manipulate it in different kinds
of ways, I think the opportunities
for creativity just kind of go
through the roof and people can
do all sorts of different things
with music and so one of the
things we've seen is the rise
of what you'd call headphone
music where there's all
of this attention to sonic detail.
You see it in the clip from The
Beatles, Tomorrow Never Knows,
that's a song that you can
listen to in a pair of headphones
and just hear all of the effects
like panning where a sound goes
from the left side to the right
side, you can hear the treatment
of John Lennon's voice in that
song and so on so there's a lot
of effects that take place
in music that are intended
for headphone listening and also
listening to music on the go
so the idea of listening to music
for instance at the gym means
that you're going to
have different type
of artist making different types
of music for particular experiences
that have to do with mobility.
>> Eric Schwartz: And
better listening, I assume
or better listeners is something
that all creators can only hope for.
I guess the question for Steve,
changing the topic, is the challenge
of trying to protect your
creative works in this technology
and this is something
for both of you.
>> Steve Bogard: No doubt well,
you mention the streaming services.
The streaming services
now are the primary source
of recorded music income in
the United States for this year
for the first time so the protection
of intellectual property in terms
of music, we've had
the longest battle.
Film is a little bit shorter
battle but I can remember
when Napster became really
popular, I had a new song coming
out on an album by a country group
and the album was set for release
in a few days and I did an internet
search and it was available free
on 1,100 different sites
and I knew at that point,
that at least for this
little segment we were kind
of in a bad state.
Part of that is the clinging
nature of major labels at the time,
the panic of loss of control,
which caused I think some decisions
that they've decided to
rethink at this point.
But, at this point the
protection of streaming has kind
of replaced piracy in
many ways since it's
so ubiquitous and so inexpensive.
That's the good news and for
the sound recording copyright,
in my research it approaches
fairness,
it approaches what a person might
earn if they were selling their CDs.
There's all kinds of
formulas, on 100 streams,
what a download would be or 150
streams what a download would be.
When you're 12, you might
listen to your single 300 times
and when you're 40, you might
listen twice but you still buy it
so the unfortunate part and the
part that I've worked on a lot is
that the underlying work,
the publishing copyright is
so restricted by outdated laws that
the laws have not caught up with it,
that as streaming becomes more
ubiquitous and as sales disappear,
the way to make a living
for a nonperforming songwriter is
becoming much, much more difficult.
The catalogue income that
many songwriters depend
on is falling off a cliff so I think
the main theme here for me as far
as protecting rights is not
just it isn't the services fault
that the laws allow them to charge
a ridiculously unfair royalty,
it is incumbent upon all of us to
make those changes, to support guys
like Doug Collins who are
working slowly but surely,
"Lordy don't the wheels turn
slow " to quote Alan Jackson.
If we can change the laws
and the consent degrees
and let my people go, I think
if we could actually negotiate
the way the labels do,
I think the technology is
going to be a great boon
for both creators and the public.
>> Eric Schwartz: Yeah, I mean I
think the last 20 years the perfect
storm of technology, which
is nothing to criticize,
a generational change
of a generation not understanding
why you would pay for music.
I remember asking my law school
students wait, you're the generation
who will pay three
dollars for a cup of coffee
but you won't pay a dollar
for a downloaded song.
Mine was just the opposite,
I don't get it.
You have the combination of things
and then antiquated laws
and that's where we are.
I do think though, that the goal,
Jason you refer to the ubiquity
of music and making music and the
ability of technology to make it
but the goal here is to
have a professional class.
I mean, you're both professionals.
You're writers, you're performers,
you get up every day and you write
and it's the ability to
sustain an income doing that,
not just the ability of hobbyists
or those of us, in my case I peaked
as a guitarist at 14,
to be able to do that
but to have the professionals
be able to do
that and to keep doing that.
>> Steve Bogard: That
was a big point.
I just testified two weeks ago at
the Copyright Royalty Board and one
of our main points was to
actually accentuate the fact
that there is a difference between
amateur and professional content.
You can watch Jerry Springer
or you can watch Downton Abbey
and it's fun, amateur
content is great
but professional content
is different
and the non-performing
songwriter will disappear
if we don't address these issues.
>> Jason King: I think also,
I've always asked my students I've
been teaching about 17 years at NYU,
I always ask my students over the
years how many of you buy music
and I have seen the
numbers drop to nothing.
>> Eric Schwartz: And it's not good
or bad it's just that's what it is,
and it's the reality we live with.
>> Jason King: Yeah, what the
internet did is mostly for worse,
I think it changed the perceptual
value of music to almost zero
for a lot of young people and so
the interesting thing is that all
of my students are aspiring
songwriters and producers
and engineers and so on,
and so I say to them well,
if you don't buy music how do
you plan to make money from music
and then they're like oh, I've got
to think about that a little bit.
I'm like, that moment
of confusion there
for you is an important
one to consider.
>> Eric Schwartz: Merchandising,
they're going to sell
a lot of t-shirts.
>> Jason King: Exactly but
streaming services are here to stay
and I think it's been a slow
journey to get there but I think now
since they're here, I see
my students using them
in particular ways that
are also very creative too.
They write songs that are shorter
because the idea of writing a song
that was four minutes
long is something
that was created around
the radio format.
Now that we have streaming
and that's the primary way-
>> Eric Schwartz: Or a double
album or a triple album format.
>> Jason King: All of
that, so it's interesting
to see how creativity is
even shifting in the age.
>> Steve Bogard: It's
almost full circle
from Doug Collins' description of
the 45 that he bought for 99 cents.
It's almost come full circle
and it's totally changed the
way we write in Nashville,
and it's totally changed
the way we produce albums.
She was talking about one good
song and 18 bad songs but often,
some of the classic albums were
a journey that you could go
on for a good 30 minutes and
just interrupt long enough
to flip the side, but they
always had various aspects
of what the artist wanted to do.
Ten years ago in Nashville,
the art piece was an essential
part of every album we did.
The thing that George Strait
or Tim McGraw recorded
that wasn't necessarily perfect for
radio, you didn't necessarily dance
to it, but people would find it
and go oh man, listen to that
and they'd tell their friends
and an album would sell.
>> Eric Schwartz: Deep
listening, as it was called.
So, we've talked about technology
a lot but we're going to look
at a final clip which in some ways
is my favorite five minute clip
from episode 103, called
The Human Instrument,
which focused on the human
voice but more importantly,
this segment is how emotions
and imperfections play a role
in creativity and innovation
in the studio.
[ Applause ]
>> Eric Schwartz: Now that's
really Linda Perry at her best,
being right in the
moment as artists.
I mean you know, imperfections and
emotion, and that is the connection
of all art, it's the emotional
connection and it's the antithesis
of the technology segments
and the technology discussion.
I'll start first with you
to talk about imperfections
and failures and creativity.
>> Steve Bogard: Well, I spent some
time in Memphis in my early days
and worked with Charlie Rich and
Jerry Lee Lewis and so was familiar
with the Sam Phillips family.
You've got to laugh when
you say Jerry Lee Lewis.
He almost broke my knees with a
piano bench once but when you think
about Sam Phillips and what he
did in creating rock and roll,
I'm kind of quoting the
Peter Guralnick book,
is one of his ongoing themes
was perfect imperfection
and he would argue and go to the
wall and he'd let people sing
but he'd go nope, you missed it.
That was the take,
that was the take,
the one that created the
emotion and the connection
between the artist and the audience.
When multitrack recording and
digital copying became so easy,
analog copying was a nightmare but
when digital copying became so easy,
by copying I mean taking five
vocal passes or 100 vocal passes
and picking the best parts of
each and creating a composite.
As a producer, I couldn't stand to
listen to 10, 12 different versions
of a vocal so as the vocal went
down, I had a little cheat sheet
and I would make little marks on
each line on the lyric that had,
I didn't care about pitch too
much, that had a little gravel,
a little hiccough, a Haney,
a little yodely effect,
something that I thought might
communicate the song better,
the emotion the best, and then
I would hand it to the engineer
and go all right, you're in charge.
You can do pitch and you can
move the time but I want a lot
of this stuff in it, and a lot
of people do that to this day.
>> Eric Schwartz: Jason, are
you a fan of the imperfection?
>> Jason King: Sure, I mean I'm a
perfectionist so I'm always like no,
I don't want any mistakes but then
of course I actually really
do love the leaving space open
for imperfection and for
things to occur so I'm working
on a book called Blue Magic and it
looks at feeling in popular music,
because I think music is a conduit
for feeling and so for instance,
if you go to see an Aretha
Franklin concert, you would expect
for some kind of soulful
transference of feeling to happen
in the concert and actually,
you would judge the concert
by whether it was soulful or not,
not whether she hit every
single note exactly on pitch
but whether there was a kind
of soulful feeling in the room,
whether the hair stood up
on the back of your neck.
That's actually how music is moving
you, it's moving through space,
it's vibrational, it's effecting
you on a vibrational level
so I'm really attracted to that
aspect of music, which is very hard
to talk about because we don't
have really a physical language
to discuss it, but
it is so essential
to the cultural power of music.
I just finished liner notes
for the R&B artist D'Angelo,
it's a boxed set that's
coming out of his 90s albums
and he was particularly influenced
in terms of the rhythm of some
of his work by a hip-hop producer
named J Dilla, who passed away,
but J Dilla was one of the most
influential producers in hip-hop
over the last 20, 30 years and one
of the things that J Dilla was good
at was making sure that
when he would program drums,
in other words not using
an actual live drum set
but actually using drum samples,
you can go into recording software
and actually line up the samples
and you can use a tool
that's called quantization
where you can actually quantize the
beat and make sure it lands exactly
on the measures that you want
so instead of having kind
of sloppy drumming, you
can have exact drumming
and J Dilla was notorious
for actually moving all
of his drum samples
just a little bit off
so the sound is a little bit wonky
and kind of lurching and loping,
but it actually changed the
sound of hip-hop in the 1990s
and everybody wanted the J Dilla
sound and it actually is the sound
that empowers all of
D'Angelo's records
and he's won R&B Grammy's
for most of his records.
We'd always go in and
make sure it has this kind
of what he would call inebriated
sort of sloppy drunken feeling
to the beats and it makes no sense.
Why should a beat not
actually hit exactly right
on where you want it to,
but the whole point was
to do it deliberately to incorporate
the mistakes deliberately
to create a particular feeling
that would be powerful for people.
>> Steve Bogard: You can
actually get tempo maps
for various drummers,
whichever drum.
If you want Muscle Shoals behind
the beat you can get a Roger Hawkins
tempo map.
If you want a jazzier Steve Gadd-
>> Eric Schwartz: And only
Purdie can do the Purdie shuffle.
>> Steve Bogard: Only Purdie
can do that, he's the only one.
>> Eric Schwartz: But you know,
there are some imperfections
and then there are also the
individual performances and part
of this also is the role of the
producer in putting it all together,
when you break down
tracks and we've done that,
we did that at The Copyright Society
a few years ago with Superstition,
and you listen to Stevie Wonder's
three recordings of the keyboard
and none of them are perfect by
any means, but that's what happens
in the mixing and in the producing.
We're putting them together, no one
can say that song's not as close
to perfection as it could
be emotionally whether
or not musically, even someone as
adept as Stevie Wonder would be.
So last question and then looking
at our time, we need to wrap
up our lessons for
up and coming artists
in this day and age of tough music.
I'll start with you and so
what are the lessons for an up
and coming songwriter/performer?
>> Steve Bogard: First and foremost,
and I think we've covered some
of this, is you have to move people.
You have to create something that
moves people and I'd like to see
from the pop perspective it's
more like I'm cooler than you,
wouldn't you like to be me?
From a country perspective, it's
more like my mom gets sick too,
we're having coffee
at the kitchen table.
It's just two funnels that
go two different directions
but for new artists, I'd say
concentrate on the emotion,
concentrate on, I had a kid at
a Bluebird gig show me a tattoo
that said, "Every mile a memory"
and he and his buddy went to Iraq
and that's a song I wrote
that Dierks Bentley did and he
and his buddy went to Iraq
and they said they were going
to make memories and
come back together,
and his buddy didn't come home.
So, if you can find ways to
communicate that kind of emotion
and then secondly, I'd say in this
current climate hedge your bets.
Be a producer, be a
performer, be a singer,
or make friends with
all of the above.
[ Laughter ]
>> Eric Schwartz: And Jason?
>> Jason King: You know, I'm
director at a music school
so I'm constantly giving
advice to students,
that's literally the nature of the
classes we do but I think I agree
with Steve, I think part of
it is you need to be able
to connect what you do to your
passion so in other words,
a lot of our students
get into a state
where they are just thinking
okay, what's on the charts,
how can I be successful by sort
of gaming the system but really,
the most amazing music is some
of the most eccentric, singular,
idiosyncratic music so think of
a song like Bohemian Rhapsody,
I'm writing a book
on Freddie Mercury
so there's a song that
follows no rules.
It doesn't even have a chorus,
it's like, seven minutes long,
it's strange, it's
unusual, but it's one
of the top pop songs of all time.
It doesn't follow a formula,
so I think getting young people
to be able to reach deep into
their bones, into the marrow
of their bones and pull something
out is so meaningful to them,
that's the first step, being able
to connect deeply to what you do.
Second, I also think it's really
important to learn your craft.
I think craft is a word that
we just don't use enough
and it's really important to hone
your craft, to be able to develop,
and to shape your work over time,
and to fail and to make mistakes,
and to learn from those
mistakes and so on.
And also, I think it's really
important for young performers
to learn the business, that it
is a business, it's not just show
and that they should empower
themselves by learning how
to write contracts, read
contracts, learn how revenue flows
through a system, learn
how to protect themselves,
and all of those kinds of things and
when I think you marry that approach
to being a really talented artist
with being a really savvy business
person, I think you can do wonders.
>> Eric Schwartz: Sound advice
and the craft part is the hardest,
I think, to communicate to students.
Every writer I know, and I've
known a lot over my career
as a copyright lawyer,
gets up every day
at some point they have a schedule
and they write and you know,
90 percent of it no one ever sees
but it's improving the craft.
I've always thought too it's the
reason why copyright term was
as long as it was because
there are exceptions.
John Lennon died at 40, but most
artists of any kind, writers,
songwriters, performers, get better
as they age, as their craft improves
and so you have that
term to recognize that.
So, we are out of time and I'm
going to now turn to Karyn,
who's going to say a few closing
words I'm told and then I want
to thank very much Jason, Steve,
and Linda for your contributions
both today and beyond,
for all your hard work
and thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Karyn Temple Claggett: I will
keep my closing words very short
and just say Happy World IP Day and
just of course thank our panelists
and our moderator, thank you to Eric
Schwartz, Steve Bogard, Jason King.
This was really, truly an inspiring
and uplifting panel on World IP Day,
so we appreciate your time here.
I also want to thank the Copyright
Alliance for partnering with us
for the sixth year and
NPAA and [inaudible],
who actually provided some of
the photographs that you saw
in the earlier clip,
and Soundbreaking for
the wonderful clips.
So, thank you for a
wonderful World IP Day event.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.